our friends at manscapes are turning
their men's shower dreams into their
favorite routines the Ultra Premium new
collection is an all-in-one hygiene skin
and hair bundle it's designed to upgrade
your shower from head to toe use a
manscape during my showers after workout
has given me much more confidence the
shower routine uses all the collections
products you start with the cologne
infused Ultra Premium body wash you'll
smell so great all the ladies will be
after you next you apply the two in one
shampoo and conditioner that cleanses
once you hop out the shower apply the
manscape aluminum free deodorant if you
have tattoos or dry skin hit your skin
with the hydrating body moisturizer
spray last but not least check out the
lawnmower 4.0 electric trimmer to clean
off any unwanted body hair the lawnmower
4.0 is waterproof and so it can join you
in the shower although your balls might
look like punching bags don't don't
treat them like one the lawnmower is
designed to cut hair on loose skin hit
20 off free shipping with code the hot
boxing at manscape.com that's 20 off
free shipping with code hot boxing at
manscape.com it's time to get wet and
clean with your new manscape shower
routine I got kicked out of California
for a bunch of different crimes if you
can find me guilty of then I came back
and started a robbery crew
so basically we're just kidnap people
for a living that's a lady and you know
I was in a crossroad I didn't I knew I
didn't want to sell dope no more yeah
but at 21 22 I didn't have no other
means of income I had already amassed
like I was my I had two little brothers
in private school I had so many pieces
of property all over the place trying to
pay for that so now I'm stuck with all
this debt monthly it's like [ __ ] all
right I gotta figure something out so it
was to the hustle what I knew best was
the gun
another installment of hot boxing I'm
Mike Tyson this is my whole silver hair
bath and we have big you as a guests
talk to a big girl
you know X crew x-crip activist now tell
us your story
all around Humble God no
oh man that's a start
I'm pretty much like most people from
L.A you know we came from a Game Pass
like yourself around the streets started
off early
um
started going to jail about 14. no my
first time getting shot was 14. and um
really kind of like found the streets
and I got kicked out of California for a
bunch of different crimes if you
couldn't find me guilty of so they
kicked me out of California I went to
Chicago for a while then I found my way
back to LA 85 84 85 cocaine was at the
height at that time and so you know dove
into that got a lot of money into that
went back to jail
86 85 87. had a lot of
terrible cases ended up luckily beating
those came on 87 same thing went back
now left went to Minnesota for a little
while hustled up there
feds ran me out of there
then I came back and started a robbery
crew
so basically we just kidnap people
for a living that's a lighting and you
know
and I actually that's the first time I
met you like tell me about that when uh
um Jim Brown House oh yeah Jim Brown
House with me you and stone might be
going with stone y'all do business
was our big homie that's what I looked
up to okay so when he got killed he was
the one that put the newspapers the
leader wrote the 60s I was supposed to
be next but Stone and Jim Brown was was
real tight when he started American
program so that was my first time
becoming conscious of being conscious
towards stopping the violence so on my
relationship with Jim at form and I kind
of backed up off the streets that's that
right after that I cut my hair off and I
met Mr Lewis Farrakhan who had a great
influence on me of course I was already
born into Islam but I took the way away
off and so that really brought me back
and so from there
I kind of started robbing because I
didn't want to sell dope no more because
that means they don't understand that
I know that sounds weird I started
robbing I didn't want to felt dope but I
understand that okay no can you want to
detail about that though so people can
understand why so I read Malcolm's
autobiography of course and then I was
on the road I was taking some some drugs
from Minnesota who likes to get the
drugs to Minnesota and I would take them
all throughout
um that little Tri Area Detroit St Louis
Chicago and it was a little Hub yeah so
I'm taking it I read Malcolm's
autobiography
then the feds here
in Minnesota about seven months after
that but I stayed in Chicago studying
then I came back home and I hooked up
with Dr Khaled Muhammad me calek you
were having some licks back then though
oh yeah I was killing them yeah I'm
listening to this from Lexi in here yeah
I hear these people's name I'm hearing
these lips
from Big names
yeah so I linked up with Dr Kelly when I
came back to L.A because he was um he
was over 27 at the time and um so me
Khaled Malik we hooked up and um I
started moving all the brothers to
through Jim Brown to the nation and now
but I like I said it was it was kind of
like I was in a crossroad I didn't I
knew I didn't want to sell dope no more
yeah but at 21 22 I didn't have no other
means of income I'd already amassed like
I was my I had two little brothers in
private school I had so many pieces of
property all over the place trying to
pay for that so now I'm stuck with all
this debt monthly it's like [ __ ] all
right do something I gotta figure
something out so it was to the hustle
what I knew best was the gun yeah so I
was like basically my irrational thought
was to rob the dope dealers
exactly
a little harder not harder I was telling
myself
somebody's gonna rob you
right that's what's going to happen
right your friend's gonna rob you even
yeah all day like a smock wait for me to
come the cops don't get you somebody's
gonna get you yeah that's really pretty
much dope man was in the man like he is
now back then an early late 70s early
80s
so we robbed everybody
but then like I said so it really wasn't
no real outlets at that time yeah no for
sure like you like you have pretty much
now and so
I think I became an outlet yeah from
from me Jim Brown Mr Farrakhan and um
the studies and then I went to prison
shortly after that so I went to prison
for robbery and kidnapped so your hip
hop uncover dog how'd that come about
actually from um one of our partners
named Jimmy Chris okay we were all we
were all trying to do get some kind of
documentary off and get something about
hip-hop and Jimmy Chris came with what I
did to do one about bodyguards so it was
really about it really supposed to be
about bodyguards bodyguards worked in
the industry and then it went to be
about managers and so
I had an idea for a documentary that was
called that I wanted to call it the sons
of um
Superfly not Malcolm and Martin okay so
I was going to detail the fact that we
grew up in the 60s I was born in the 60s
but like me and Mike but we didn't we
didn't get we didn't get the influence
of Malcolm Martin and we actually got
the influence the superfly so I watched
with my uncle them were really all on
the Black Power movement too and then
they turned in to Super Superfly after
the superfly movie came out so that's
still a phenomenal that I wanted to
touch on because we kind of got lost in
between that and then you seen the
exploitation the black film of course I
was a baby but I could see what that
result was so it wasn't nobody really
teaching us like on the west coast how
to really become black man yeah and so
then until I got to prison and started
reading and studying myself I never even
knew who you repeat Newton was nor did I
add no clue on H Drive Brown
um the Soledad Brothers these are stuff
that we learned in prison George Jackson
like you know he was he was a phenomenal
figure that's untalked about
but like so that side of the documentary
came because so we added what we don't
want to do from that to that and then it
kind of started moving up the ladder and
it's shaped into what it's shaped in
talking about the legends of hip-hop to
people who were pretty much untalked
about on unheard of and so
right I think
we did the deal right before Nipsey got
killed so we had I think maybe about a
month month and a half and so that
really kind of helped me again shape it
to talk about people who were untalked
about are unrecognized in the hip-hop
industry so we try to do that stay with
that it was pretty successful and you
just you kind of um mentioned so Nipsey
man your relationship with him you won't
like talk about that yeah yeah yeah
you're meeting them nip grew up in our
neighborhood like we all come up about
the 60s so my nephew I thought I was
dealing with sugar when I came home in
2004 I started dealing with sugar I
dealt with sugar for about the first
three four years okay and then it was I
thought it was time for me to find my
own artist so I came back to the
neighborhood and I started looking for
artists all my little homies you know
you put the search out and so from there
so I'm like all right we want to find
Nipsey
play some of his music he played a lot
of songs that we loved I loved
immediately so then I started going back
but
he got a song called keys to the city
where he says Dr Dre turned him down
epic turn everybody turned him down and
then in the Assassin the song he says
big use an animal because he tells the
story of how he was turned down up until
he went into me and then I took him to
Steve Lobel almost a couple of people
Steve eventually took him took him
introduced us to John Shapiro which got
assigned a cinematic epic and then from
there it just kind of took off then it
dropped and then I left the music and
then I started managing Ving range and I
really started I really was with Vine
for about six years doing movies
but yeah no when I met nip man he was
what 18
fresh out and everything in his in his
in his repertoire was about the hood RSC
he had a song called RSC it was uh
bullets don't got no name it was killed
him up shoot him a bang bang and so I
think my influence at the time and where
I was at that time helped influence to
shape him yeah to where we eventually
see him get to because
he became a phenomenal leader
and to see where he came from and the
road that we all traveled to get there
in itself was great yeah that's the
biggest thing he just tell us a
intelligent guy man like you always read
yeah always yeah he read all the time so
we just sit in my basement he said in
the song we just sit in my basement
and and talk about books all the time
because I was a real mild fan when I
came home in 2004 I wanted to tell
everybody had to get out of our
neighborhood
in our neighborhood I didn't want nobody
coming leaching off our neighborhood
because everything is Crenshaw so now
because of the way
our community is safe we are like the
last black Enclave
in almost California wow and so most of
people come to Crenshaw to leech off
that's black culture and then but people
don't understand how greatness of the
block Crenshaw from the span of Florence
all the way down to King Boulevard
that's always been a rich a rich street
from the Gap Band from from George
Clinton Harlem used to be on Crenshaw
because they couldn't go to Beverly
Hills they had no student Beverly Hills
so it was Crenshaw and people don't
understand the the history that's on
Crenshaw so when I came home
I wanted to push that yeah you know I
mean because Captain was Compton Drake
them at Compton snooting them at Long
Beach but we didn't have nothing on our
section so my whole thing was not we
from this area like we're going to
celebrate us and we already had movies
with Ice Cube them and celebrated us and
talked about us you had moisian artists
but it wasn't a movement that came out
of Crenshaw and only pushed our block
yeah and so that was our intentions and
that's that was really successful in
doing that's hard that's hard it's hard
so you got a new book coming out
yeah we working on the book I'm 55 years
old so it's my story goes so far back
what part is always like what part do
you want and then they they asked me
stories and one thing to remind me of
something else you know how your story
is like more people can tell you about
the [ __ ] you did yeah then you can
remember
that's the trip we have to think back
and back when you were a kid before you
had gray in your bed yeah see how fast I
can't believe I'm here
that's a stupid kid
I remember when I got a story where Emma
Stone was flying birds the stone was his
dog had birds and I always say that's
why them dudes got them big ass necks
watch these Birds because that's not him
and my big homie hooked up yeah he was
light-skinned with green eyes about his
height and he flew birds and when Jim
told him that he I was shocked when I
came on the Block on my homework it was
the first one out all of us to have a
house on 60th and he had like three
pigeon cages yeah and I get to his house
and wrote it if you got opinions I go
anywhere yes no lie my kind of birds
rolling some real real first class Birds
I go anywhere like eagles bald eagles
vultures no I'm talking about my rolling
pigeons
I go to China to watch him I go to
Africa all over the world England so
even everywhere yeah they was playing my
homeboy was paying thirty thousand
dollars for birds
in in 90 89 90 and I'm like bro this is
crazy
the most expensive bird is a
2.1 pigeon that's the racers right
racing business yeah most expensive
racing pictures you're not two million
bucks how much is it 1.99 that's crazy
yeah
yeah
Jesus you should never let it go it's
Gotta breathe it it's got it right back
home and I mean my own ways to have well
I mean we grew up we used to hit pigeon
cages
oh yeah
I was in New York we got my [ __ ] right
off the roof okay
that's two million well no no it's gonna
cost that no we're listening the passion
that we have in it costs more than 2
million okay we catching you in trouble
no lie your account people for pigeons
bro and then I honestly were dudes and
beat the call somebody in their cage I
caught them and beat him and left them
in the cage with two three they didn't
finally let him go
and
um these white boys um
I'm trying to steal their Birds but they
had an alarm on the coops when I came to
hurt me and man I had to like jump from
here it was just crazy I could have
killed myself they were beating my ass
when they come in they were just gonna
feel gonna throw me off the roof but I
guess the working people now said hey
what's going on up there he said this
guy was trying to tell my brother to do
it again but throw them out the roof
saying let me go I said Thank God that's
a true tube workers in California you
know we got better weather yeah so it's
it was a real big
like I remember they used to go from
place to place house to highlight their
meat at certain times in the morning and
then driving and
I mean one time Stone it was a Hulk a
pigeon Hulk when this man had us up to
five in the morning to go waiting for
this now wait to go climb the tree yes
serious right there kind of fine boy
first time ever
and they won't live though those some of
those Hawks they were just starve
themselves if you catch them some of
them they'll sit in there they won't eat
right you can't even feed them it's
crazy that he would refuse to be
captivity
it's crazy
now that's a whole different world y'all
just y'all just brought me a whole
different way I never heard anything
about this I had some outdoor stuff
around this big I kept two Hawks in
there
they survived live headaches
yeah that's big huh yeah you kept him in
Albert who they going to burn they get
caught in the Trap oh that's how you
catch them yeah yeah that was I was
phenomenal with that catching the marks
it was too big for me that mean looking
oh they catching them mean when they
spread out they spread as long as that I
don't I don't like birds not big birds
like that I'm feeling trying to grab his
feet and he he just went right across
the beach just like this like six
stitches come right over blood
just touches went across and didn't even
bite the bird didn't bite the birds
speak and split his finger right open
you know I don't [ __ ] with birds Mike I
don't do that that birds that mean so
how big this brother is we're gonna
bring a bird in here next time
I'm like well he's talking about like
the Hawks the Eagles
vultures I ain't [ __ ] with that
that's some prehistoric [ __ ] yeah what's
up brother yeah man that's nice that's
not really good good luck
so growing up in that in in the streets
right how and obviously no one Nipsey
how pivotal was seeing Nipsey and YG
have that Union between them no I was
great for the culture it wasn't just
them it was a message for the culture
because at the time it was kind of
getting back Rocky with red and blue so
the union between Nipsey and YG
it helped the culture helped help help
young kids from wherever side you was
from realize you can have a friend
or a partner so that message was even
bigger than just music you know it
resonated around the country but it was
bigger for art for us for our culture to
see that you know I mean that's Gravely
important you know to see what's
happening because I mean you know you
see it's so much travesty in the world
and you see what's going on with Putin
and all Limitless crazy bro so you know
that Union with them too was was great
yeah yeah definitely definitely our
pizza is a great nipsy man yeah so
I'm just curious to hear your opinions
on
on how on how to stop the violence man
like you know you know there's been a
couple artists that's been getting
killed like at least five I could think
of off the top of my head recently right
so
I don't really think it's I think each
individual situation is different
because some may put theirself in a
situation and then situation may arrive
everyone is different it's not like one
you got somebody doing a carjack you can
say you don't do no carjacking don't do
nothing and you can't tell somebody not
to go
hustled they're not hustling like nip
situation is different than pop smokes
yeah facts young adult situation is
different than each one of theirs yeah
so there's no right way but I think nip
said it the best he said that if he
changed the energy he put out in his
music
so he would get different energy back
yeah so maybe if we change the energy we
put out in our music it'll help bring
positive more positive energy back and
as you get older you change anyway you
know I mean
we all go from a natural stage of growth
to not doing what we was doing with his
kids you know so I think it's getting
wiser yeah there's some people who don't
but
yeah you get some people that don't the
internet is really powerful but this
internet
is a powerful tool that
I think too many people have too much
access with their thumbs to do this
stuff it is true you know I mean you can
just get out there yeah because we don't
really like kids the internet does
okay how much house strict we all I
can't take that phone that phone calls
Mrs drugs to them that's their first
um experiment experience with an
addiction
yeah
because every time my daughter room not
clean first thing I say to is give me
that phone
she up the stairs in the room cleaning
the room but I think um not now I think
I I deal with I have my audience is
called development option so we deal
with
you find it so I have one that won the
contracts in the city to deal with gang
intervention so we deal with I had 21
people to work for me I've been doing
that for 18 years so we've been
instrumental in dropping the gang
violence down in L.A tremendously but we
see a different kind of violence yeah
talk about that yeah and it's not so
much red and blue no more okay so that
guy's in a union between Nipsey and YG
we see where it's more drug related
now because we have more drugs more kids
using drugs hardcore drugs yeah or what
can be sitted prescription drugs than
ever before because we used to can kind
of have it I think my mother my parents
Heir was the pure air that was a that
was a Red Devils all the different
things they used to use now we're back
to that to where you see a lot of
prescription drugs
all that stuff so right now we deal with
something different so
in the schools
we have to watch the Instagram and we
have to know which kids are to have the
most influence and so you have something
like one kid may put up a post and
another kid and say oh your shoes are
dirty and then that turns into something
else if they get five or six people
laughing now they want to meet and fight
at school the next day and so from them
fighting at school the parents are now
showing up at school and the parents are
fighting like we had this all the time
you know what I mean so then that that
turns into something else if it becomes
that and so everybody's too sensitive
now oh man and this internet is really
crazy like these comments there's so
many issues over comments in the
internet yeah like that's a major it's
crazy it's a major drag in what we do
and we see it coming how do we stop that
how do we stop such a you know stop
comments before I think you got to tell
them because make this [ __ ] private I
mean because no I really do we really
deal with that like every single day we
deal with it how many suicides you get
we'll have a lot of suicide man I got a
lot of kids you know I had
I had was crazy you said that because I
had a six year no a six-year-old talking
about she was just gonna kill herself
and get out the way
and you know you get parents how do you
even deal with that as a parent yes you
know what I mean because
it's so much stuff that's on TV
and then they say the rate of a black
man killing themselves but black the
suicide with black men is not just
suicide it's mental illness so we're
dealing with more mental illness now
than we ever dealt with before like I
dealt with my own family but it's
because of this prescription drugs that
they don't realize that they take it
because you got you got these young men
taking drugs not realizing that the
drugs that they're taking is meant to
help somebody who has a mental illness
if you don't have a mental illness and
you're taking mental drugs it's meant
for mental illness don't you realize
it's going to cause a mental illness
I just believe it's just big business oh
yeah America is a is a business country
the country for business
I'm not knocking what nobody do I just
think that
what what we have to realize that is
right and wrong is wrong right that's
right wrong is wrong what we're not
realizing is that the um these drugs
that they taking is going to have an
effect on them so it's not like he's
smoking marijuana you know what I mean I
think marijuana got a drag a bad name
in this so people equate it with all the
other drugs you know like real hardcore
drugs yeah and so it needed to be
separated and be isolated if you're
taking certain drugs and it's meant to
alter your brain yeah it needs to be
focused on but listen um
they they tell you right after um
what can happen after effects can happen
you can die you can go blind you can let
you know they're arrogant you know
because they know you're gonna still
take it mm-hmm
after knowing this is gonna make you
blind I bust your guts open and all that
stuff you still take it what is the
worst experience you've ever had with
the police officer and and obviously and
obviously what are your thoughts with
the whole George Floyd like where were
you when the whole George Floyd incident
happened well my worst experience was
oh
like these knots right here
right here
right here
and I think on the back you're a big
[ __ ] [ __ ] you they thought I was they
didn't know I was grown yeah one of my
partners did a robbery he didn't know
how to drive the car he just took
so I knew how to drive a stick I jumped
the stick and I take off I get caught
down the street they beat the dog crap
out of me when they realized after we
get to the station they put me in there
one of my homeboys we just went to Magic
Mountain earlier that day and he was
getting arrested he was all dressing
like so they had me in a grown man tank
I couldn't see I couldn't hear nothing
uh head was a balloon totally
discombobulated and I wake up again and
he in the tank with me he had told them
who I was and he had told him I was a
juvenile so then after that
you know um that was my worst experience
again then after I had another
experience with them and this time I
went and then you know it kind of it
worked the other way around and I ended
up that's how I learned how to fight
that's how I learned a lot about the law
because I ended up catching the case in
the county jail on some assaults and
some stats but of course I didn't have
nothing to do with it but I thought the
case nevertheless so that's when I
learned the law and I like to tell
people when I went to prison I couldn't
read nor right so but while in prison I
learned how to read and write wow and so
I had learned the law fight in that case
and but I already have been found guilty
was on my way to a prison so I think it
was Tookie me when I was my first time I
mean Tookie Tookie was in his tank
behind me
and we was just talking about
the law and he was like you know how
much you know about the law you know you
and Justin that I think we was there for
like 30 45 days he came down to fight
a child custody case so he was coming I
can't remember what he was down there
for but we was talking through the vents
you can talk through the vents with the
back and uh he was like man you need to
know your case know your love but then
like I said I just contacted snap drove
me to the law library and from there
I just feel like now I'm equipped I can
I can maintain myself when it comes to
speaking that language yeah because when
they gave me they sentenced me
they sentenced me and they talked about
me in the courtroom in a way that in
their languages I I understand I
couldn't understand the word they were
saying about it you know what I feel
they in the courtroom they may meet they
talked about me and trial so bad I
wanted to find me guilty like I was like
I was like but the language they were
using
I was at a distance it's so foreign
language that we speak and so I I found
out about a thing called the black Law
Dictionary so then I picked up the black
auditionary and I made that a part of my
everyday reading wow to learn certain
words and so I went on and went to
prison after that and did the 13 years
but while I was there I was a litigator
considered what it would be a litigator
because I had already knew how to write
and and what people would fit what fills
us as as as young men is that the law is
not hard uh I think what 75 percent of
the laws is just a leaflet
in any writ or any any motion you want
to file is already written up write your
name write your case down and explain a
little bit of what how it fits you and
submit it and that's how it goes but
that right there escapes so many of us
yeah and they teach us that we have to
get a lawyer that was like you know my
my worst experience with them but while
I was in prison
I became so good
you know I was able to deal with that do
you know I still ended up in the hole
and
they did their thing so what's the
biggest lesson you probably learned in
all of your experiences in life so far
reading reading
reading
you gotta read
and to be honest with you my biggest
experience was
another experience from prison when I
first got to prison
of course when I got there everybody
blessing me the homies looking out when
I get to the seven Center they send me a
TV a radio high plate and all that
you're not even supposed to have that
wow so when I got there like I said
because I had just came out of purple
tank
I read the title 15. it's a book they
give you on everything you can do and
you're not supposed to do I read the
title 15 because you're in the sale by
yourself and I'm in the sale by myself
waiting to go to orientation I read the
title 15 and I just remembered it
so after reading the title 15
they came in my cell when I went to
child took this TV took everything and
just trashed the seal
and I and I'm and I just wrote a 602
form from memory from from because they
wouldn't give me us that's crazy and I
just quoted it wrote it like it would be
a law like like you know you presented a
a 1983 form which is a civil suit and
when I was going out to go to Chow I
slid under the police door
when I came back they had a whole bag
of everything they took from me it was
like we can't get you the TV we'll give
you the radio if you can pull it back
and so at that time it was it was my
first experience yeah of understanding
reading and having knowledge because
that's something they can't ever take
from well that's amazing that's amazing
story it can break you down your body
can get old yeah your limbs you're tired
whatever have you but what you once you
read it
and you consume it away from me so where
were you during the whole George Floyd
thing and and how do you feel obviously
about the whole police brutality thing
that's going on
that's been going on honestly but now
finally being highlighted
I mean I feel like
I'm wavered because
I'm just not gonna let it happen with me
no more
like to me
it ain't no getting away with it
and until we fight
it's gonna continue to happen we just
seen an elected president yeah last
night said he wanted to fund the police
what that means to him that he'll give
the police more money to fight to kill
more black and kill more black people so
it's not gonna stop until we make it
stop physically but the the sublime
results that we got from that brother's
life been taken our steps in the
direction that we need we need those
steps also but we also need to stand up
though you know we do something about it
yeah it can't be about talk though yeah
because just to be honest with you
they ain't putting their hands on me
that ain't gonna happen I'm not letting
it go
I'm gonna go to where George Jackson
chairman George
I believe in that you know I mean and
and they know they won't give us that
picture
they're not gonna give us chairman
George you know and then uh and his
brother Jonathan Jonathan tell the
people real quick who chairman who uh
chairman George is I think the Saturday
brother chairman George you know
chairman George Jackson and Jonathan
Jackson
um I think you I don't even want to tell
you I think you need to read about them
or go and really do some some time
investigating them because they
influence California prisons and so I
don't know how prisons are in other
places I've never been nowhere else in
prison but California prison we do have
a little bit of structure and we move in
a different kind of way at least I did
so
I feel Jackson stayed in isolation yeah
he got an isolation after he made his
move
yeah that he did a demo he was he was
actually charged with the murder of was
it really he was charged that's what the
um that's what the um um Saturday
Brothers about the murder of a cop who
was shot another and killed another
brother that happened when he was in
prison though yeah he went to prison for
like picking stealing like candy bar
there or something like that yeah 77 he
ended up doing uh 11 years that turns
into life him dying in prison and his
brother he told convinced
um Jonathan to go on a robbery a bank
robbery with it no no Jonathan Jonathan
actually kidnapped the judge yeah that's
what it was to to to get him out but we
want to tell the whole story though who
are the people that have their research
how do you research
Joe Jackson
um he's the first brother that got me
conscious that got you conscious he
actually gave us he actually gave us
names names like Stokey Carmichael he
actually gave his names like Angela
Davis because he became famous I don't
know
and when you research it you're going to
see that that's when she her name really
took off her judge started talking about
George is a bad cat that's so smooth
so what are some of the wildest prison
stories you got that was the most crazy
story none of them are pretty
I only had a lot of wild prison stories
I was kind of like
you know I wouldn't know what no people
knew
they do not
kind of like you know we we just it was
it's just Catholics like you know we had
uh incidents on the yard imprisoned
yours and it wasn't never really started
about me because I said kind of up there
yeah and and nobody really came to come
up to the message it would be interested
young fellas would get into not knowing
the rules and when I went if you talk
when I went to the shoe I went to the
shoe for actually an incident between
one guy in my homeboy rest in peace
right now and I knocked his eye out
so no I went to the whole idea three
years for that so we had an incident and
we ended up getting into it uh caught
him with a right and
he went down his eye
was in his hand and I ended up getting
locked up I got charged with with that I
actually stayed in the whole four years
so
a guy in 2004 so I think I went to the
whole like 90
8 98 99 something like that I got 2004
but you know like like I said that was
one that was documented and then you
know
15 days out of that you know amongst the
Cody
yeah I never I was never been in the
same space monster was like the folklore
to us we I'm three years younger than
Cody
you know I mean and so we was we was
always looking at the right thing he's
always right be in prison we both was in
prisoners to write each other yeah I
seen that somewhere he's the right Tupac
Cody was Cody was an enigma man he if if
he could have stayed stayed straight
he'd have been he'd have been a Mark I
look up to him I got a lot of respect
for him you know some people just can't
live out here yeah this was a trip for
some people's mind yeah it's that
challenge you know what he talking about
is we got homies who who can navigate
while they're in prison incarcerated
because that that everything has
penmanship
yeah I seen something is right yes right
very intellectual style but when he came
here the discipline of not dealing with
you know falling to that that that crave
he couldn't have leg he couldn't master
that
but
he was a great adversary because he was
adversary to us
so you know he was he was a gangster we
was the 60s and
he was a legend
sure can't take that Defender he's right
to you Mike he said hey we made each
other fire he was trying to recruit me
bro no way talking about time you're out
here you're out here can we talk about
this man knocking people's eyes out why
don't you do that that was wrong
eyes out of this [ __ ] like it's casual I
was boxing I would I was boxing but I
grew up in martial arts though uh
fighting man
I boxed I did a box first you know I
mean I grew up martial arts a boxer deer
wrestling I did all that so I was really
kind of cheating I was like Mike so when
I went up against dudes in the streets
you were like it was nothing
it was cheap like Mike could tell you if
he go up against the dude right now he
gonna if a dude throw a punch he gonna
be looking like damn I could do like
five techniques yeah this [ __ ] come in a
mile away
you know what I'm saying and then with
me
opposite of Mike is I knew three
differences I knew I did martial arts
and he was a master at boxing you know I
wasn't as good as boxing as he was but I
was good at a lot of other things and
then being six being six three you know
what I'm saying and and it was different
yeah it is different we was taught to
fight multiple people so we would go in
train the fight you know and doing that
because then I cheat though because I'm
gonna put your eye out hey that's what
Bruce Lee said too Michael I mean there
ain't no fair ones in these streets did
the same thing he said do you ever think
about
um the action do you ever think about
grappling me for you know why would I
think about grappling when I think about
grappling that means I'm on the floor he
said yeah that's what it's about he said
but I'm fighting four people though you
can't be on the floor and you're
fighting four people
you know my whole thing is ours is you
got three seconds to get them out of
there so we was taught
what you gonna do to get him out of
there I'm gonna cut you
so I'm gonna do all kind of [ __ ]
speaking of that speaking of that yeah
is it true you've been shot seven times
[ __ ] you God seven times yeah my first
time was 14.
uh well 14 or 15 I was in the Broadways
I was with Cubone you know Cubone
and uh I ended up getting shot so yeah
I've been shot
I've been shot uh seven different times
seven different instruments my first
time was here
here
um here here
you should be grateful to be walking
yeah
all the legs both legs all different
times all these bullet wounds what yeah
this one was hey Katie came through the
car door
and then shot my hit my cousin so we he
driving and they came through the door
through my leg out here this was this
big and it just wasn't hit him in the
side worst feeling in the world huh or
Worse pain in the world
this one was
hot hurt let's talk about now all the
amazing things you're doing right now as
an activist in the community
um could you go into that well like I
said develop an option man we have been
instrumental in California
in dropping the game right yeah sure the
lowest was being in in history we have
seen a rise since covet
because covet is such an oxymoron and
they got people in the in the house but
now they're trying to come out and and
then when you give all these people
that's PPP money you put more money into
an economy and then now you drive it but
then it drops
so we see more rivalries happening and
but we have we have enjoyed not seeing
the gang violence rise
so now like I said we look at we're now
we're looking at the violence
differently
so I've had over the years I've had
about nine of our boys come out of my
program that's made to the NFL oh wow
very happy about that we put over 400
500 kids through college in college and
now because I've been having 18 years
and so
we do the biggest Banquets
we do the biggest Banquets in in in
history for our kids we have
we have multiple kids in college I got
my my my youngest son just graduated
from uh Reno Nevada I got Dixie State
one of Dixie State one at UCLA like I
said my son of Reno just went to
Washington UCLA and all of them come out
of our program so we have a we have
football track we have a travel
basketball league we have we haven't got
to get that back started we wouldn't
know Kanye to do what he's supposed to
do we have enjoying a great deal of
success we're coming helping kids mature
we have the kids reach out to what they
want to do yeah you know I mean well
that is amazing man I you know Mike and
I just want to commend you man that's
amazing just getting back to the
community man and just doing what you
being you man it's amazing to see like
you know what I'm saying like big yeah
it's big you baby thank you amazing man
yeah I appreciate y'all having me man
thank you for coming man the world
champion over here
all right I'm all right but well there
you have it folks that is Mike Tyson I'm
Sebastian Joseph day this is big you and
this is hot boxing we out of here peace
[Music]